speaking of the future
uh you said moore's law allegedly is
dead so
do you think do you agree with uh uh
dave patterson and and many folks that
moore's law is dead
or do you agree with jim keller who says
uh who's uh standing at the helm of the
pirate ship
saying it's uh still alive it's still
alive yeah
also i agree with what they're saying
and different people are interpreting
the animals a lot in different ways
yeah so jim would say you know there's
another thousand x
left in physics and we can we can
continue to squeeze the stone and make
it
faster and smaller and smaller
geometries and all that kind of stuff
uh he's right so jim jim is
absolutely right that there's a ton of
ton of progress left
and we're not at the limit of physics
yet um
uh that's not really what moore's law is
though
if you look at what moore's law is is
that it's a very simple
uh evaluation of okay well you look at
the cost
per um i think it was cost per area and
the most
economic point in that space and if you
go look at the the
the now quite old paper that describes
this um
moore's law has a specific economic
aspect to it
and i think this is something that dave
and others often point out and
so on a technicality that's right um i
look at it from
so i can acknowledge both of those
viewpoints they're both right they're
both right
i'll give you a third wrong yeah
viewpoint that may be right in its own
way which is
um single threaded performance doesn't
improve
like it used to and it used to be back
when you got a uh
you know pentium 66 or something and the
year before you had a pentium 33
and now it's twice as fast right well it
was twice as fast at doing exactly the
same thing
okay like literally the same program ran
twice as fast
you just wrote a check okay and waited a
year a year and a half
well so that's what a lot of people
think about moore's law
and i think that is dead and so what
we're seeing instead is we're pushing
we're pushing people to write software
in different ways and so we're pushing
people to write cuda
so they can get gpu compute and the the
thousands of cores on gpu we're talking
about c programmers having used p
threads because they now have you know
100 100 threads or 50 cores in a machine
or something like that
you're not talking about machine
learning accelerators they're now domain
specific
and when you look at these kinds of use
cases
you can still get performance and jim
will come up with cool things
that utilize the silicon in new ways for
sure
but you're also going to change the
programming model right and now when you
start talking about changing the
programming model that's when you come
back to
languages and things like this too
because often what you see is
um like you take the c programming
language right the c programming
language is designed for cpus
and so if you want to talk to a gpu now
you're talking to its cousin
cuda okay cuda's a different
thing with a different set of tools a
different world a different way of
thinking
and we don't have one world that scales
and i think that
we can get there we can have one world
that scales in a much better way
you